[Musique]
Marie-Georges Buffet vous êtes une femme
engagée en politique est-ce que changer
la société est-ce que c'est encore
possible aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est encore nécessaire oui
on peut avoir nécessaire vous avez
encore de la pauvreté dans notre pays
vous avez encore des personnes qui tous
les matins se demandent si elles vont
être expulsées ou elles si elles vont
garder leur logement le droit à un toit
le droit à la santé le droit à
l'éducation ne sont pas pleinement
réalisés pour nombre de d'hommes de
femmes de jeunes donc oui il faut encore
se battre pour changer la société c'est
encore une nécessité alors les
changements seront-ils comme on les
arrivées à une époque globaux ou d'un
seul coup on passe à une nouvelle
société je me rappelle de Georges
Marchais parlant du socialisme française
voilà où est-ce que nous sommes plus
aujourd'hui dans une démarche où les
luttes les combats permettent à travers
des lois des majorités de modifier tel
et tel situation de modifier d'améliorer
tel ou tel droit c'est vrai que depuis
des décennies on est plutôt dans cette
démarche pas un changement brutal
radical mais un changement qui est plus
une bataille perpétuelle que parfois un
peu reprocher par les commentateurs et
par les Français qui disent depuis de
très nombreuses années finalement les
politiques
ils gèrent ils gèrent la France mais ils
cherchent pas l'améliorer à la changer
vous êtes d'accord avec ça c'est
excessif comme ça
qu'on vient de vivre
les viennent vivre que ce soit avec
Nicolas Sarkozy que ce soit avec
François Hollande ou avec Emmanuel
Macron les inégalités ont continué à
s'aggraver il n'y a eu aucun changement
réel
dans le sens positif pour ceux et celles
qui vivent de leur travail etc vous
seriez plutôt nostalgique bas du début
de la 5ème république justement quand le
Parti communiste était fort d'ailleurs
est-ce que ont changé plus les choses
parce qu'on améliorait plus le travers
des gouvernements d'union de la gauche
sous Mitterrand le gouvernement de
cohabitation avec Jospin il y a eu des
avancées sociales importantes je pense
par exemple je pense aux 35 heures mais
je pense à Martine Aubry au 35 heures il
y a eu des choses qui se sont passées
donc dont les personnes ont tout de
suite vécues une amélioration c'était
perceptible est-ce qu'il y a fondé vous
votre engagement politique madame buffet
peut-être le souvenir de ma mère qui
lorsqu'on avait plus d'électricité à la
maison ou plus d'eau nous expliquait que
c'était des coupures dans tout le
quartier et en fait c'est parce que
maman n'arrivait pas à payer on était
cet enfant et mon père était parti et
donc ce désir de justice sociale et puis
lorsque je suis rentré université parce
que à l'époque on pouvait poursuivre nos
études c'est pour ça que pour moi
l'école c'est au centre de la République
on avait les bourses on travaillait on
avait la chambre aussi eu quand j'ai
commencé mes études il y avait les
grandes manifestations contre la guerre
au Vietnam et j'en étais et le parti qui
à l'époque personnifiait ces deux choses
c'est-à-dire la justice sociale mais
aussi la lutte contre la guerre au
Vietnam c'était le Parti communiste
français donc j'ai décidé de le
rejoindre j'ai envoyé un courrier on m'a
répondu et avec ma réponse j'ai été voir
des camarades qui vendaient l'Humanité
Dimanche un poste on peut présenter ça a
été ma première cellule
rose avec la secrétaire de cellules je
me rappelle elle s'appelait Denise
blanche d'accord et voilà j'ai commencé
à on tirait les tracts à la rooneéo sur
sa table de cuisine
et voilà c'est comme ça j'ai commencé
mon activité militante alors je voudrais
avoir votre vision de l'histoire de
France et on va si vous voulez bien
partir de cette phrase d'un historien
évidemment grand renom Marc Bloch dans
les tranches des fêtes et qui a cette
phrase il est deux catégories de
Français qui de comprendront jamais
l'histoire de France ce qui refusent de
vibrer aux souvenirs du sacre de Reims
ceux qui disent sans émotion le récit de
la fête de la Fédération donc le 14
juillet 1990 à un an après la prise de
la Bastille donc c'est c'est en fait
l'union des deux France l'Union la
France de la monarchie et puis la France
révolutionnaire c'est l'histoire c'est
les deux pour vous y allez c'est
l'histoire du peuple du peuple de France
ce peuple de France bien sûr qui connaît
la monarchie on connaît les cerfs quand
même une forme
et puis qui finit par se révolter il y a
des révoltes et puis il y a la grande
révolution française la Fédération et
puis ensuite bon ben il y a des retours
en arrière le bonapartisme bon et puis
de nouveau des mouvements pour créer des
républiques enfin c'est l'histoire moi
je je vais pas gommer une partie de
cette histoire c'est l'histoire de notre
peuple dont toute l'histoire est
importante mais il faut aller plus loin
vous prenez la Seconde Guerre mondiale
il y a eu il y a eu de la résistance
bien évidemment et tous les ans on salue
les résistants etc mais il y a eu la
collaboration il faut la regarder en
face
c'est frais ça existait et dans la
résistance il y avait aussi bien des
gaullistes que des communistes bien sûr
et bien sûr et probablement aussi
d'ailleurs dans les dans la
collaboration il y en a eu
donc peut vivre ça dépasse de regarder
tout cela on peut ensuite se rêver si je
ne suis pas capable de regarder qu'une
partie de la France a été capable
collaboration je peux être tranquille
sur l'avenir de la France aujourd'hui je
ne suis pas tranquille je suis très
préoccupé pourquoi une partie de nos de
notre pop
n'irait pas d'être promotions avec des
régimes
autoritaires avec on n'est pas à l'abri
de cela l'histoire nous apprend à placer
quelques valeurs vraiment au dessus de
tout pour résister à toutes les
tendances au recul autoritaire au recul
au repli etc et la France les défenses
les valeurs aujourd'hui
elle y défend dans ses discours mais
évidemment liberté égalité fraternique
est-ce que la promesse de cette devise
est tenue si on prend si on prend par
exemple égalité et liberté
on s'aperçoit même un
historien qui était plutôt cassé assez à
droite qui s'appelait Jacques binville
disait en France il y a le culte de
l'égalité beaucoup plus que celui de la
liberté c'est pas vrai ça c'est
l'égalité des droits c'est à dire que
chaque individu ou qu'il naissent
a le droit la même chose ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas où
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je vais
prendre un exemple qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur c'est l'école
c'est le chemin voilà quel que soit son
origine c'est le chemin qui peut
permettre voilà
de ce construire des voilà de pouvoir
transmettre ses compétences et
connaissances ensuite au service de
notre pays bah oui vous prenez mon
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis et
quoi qu'on dise le recteur et s'il était
là je lui dirai en face aussi nous avons
moins d'enseignants qui nous en faut
pour qu'il y ait l'égalité des droits
pour les enfants de la Seine-Saint-Denis
c'est une réalité ça s'est dégradé ça
mais bien sûr et bien sûr tout le monde
sur des qualités même si on y est très
attaché ça c'est ça cette notion aime
beaucoup moins respectée que par le
passé entre les hommes et les femmes
on arrache on se bat et on arrache les
femmes il a fallu être dans la
résistance pour qu'on nous reconnaisse
le droit de voter quand même grâce au
général de Gaulle d'ailleurs après oui
puis au ministre aussi quand même et
puis il a fallu attendre 70 pour qu'on
puisse travailler sans l'autorisation du
mari ou ouvrir un compte Google sans
l'autorisation du mari et puis il a
fallu la parité pour qu'enfin on daigne
pouvoir partager le pouvoir parce que
ces messieurs quand même ils gardaient
bien le pouvoir entre les mains voilà la
France est en retard là dessus sur le
combat oui parce que la domination
patriarcale est en train et toujours
très inscrite dans les mentalités
regardez par exemple cette espèce de de
regard assez sympathique sur la
prostitution il y a eu en 2016 on a voté
une loi abolitionniste tu sais je me
suis battu ce condamné pour constitution
et condamner le client le client pas la
prostituée mais le client
ça pique pas les forces de Lourdes la
justice ça s'applique pas parce que
quand même
c'est un pays de Rivois on a une
certaine tolérance etc sauf que c'est de
tolérance on va l'appliquer aussi pour
le développement de la prostitution chez
très jeune mineur c'est un phénomène
nouveau et très important la
prostitution des très jeunes mineurs à
travers les réseaux sociaux etc et là
aussi on va avoir un regard en disant
ben
je vous écoute vous mettez l'égalité
au-dessus de la liberté non
hello prime la liberté parfois non la
liberté nous prime jamais c'est la loi
qui libère
mais la liberté elle doit se construire
avec les autres aussi elle doit pas être
que elle doit être personnelle
individuelle et liberté individuelles
c'est essentiel c'est ce qu'ils font de
la démocratie mais elle doit aussi se
partager cette liberté à ce triptyque de
notre devise nationale vous ajouteriez
là la laïcité
oui je suis très attachée à la laïcité
est-ce qu'il faut l'ajouter à cette à
cette devise si la question s'est posée
je voterai
pourquoi parce que la laïcité c'est de
dire tout simplement que chacun peut
croire chacune peut croire mais tu la
religion ne s'impose à aucun moment à la
société ni à l'État ni à la République
c'est essentiel c'est essentiel
chacun peut croire chacune peut croire
mais
on a trop de dérive et dans toutes les
religions on a trop de dérives quand
même des religions qui se mêlent de la
vie personnelle des individus qui se
mêlent de
il a fallu voter une loi à l'Assemblée
nationale pour interdire les pratiques
appliquées par certaines églises pour
comment je dirais corriger les individus
qui se déclaraient lesbiens homosexuels
etc et des familles font appel à ces
églises pour tous les enfants soient il
a fallu condamner ses thérapies de
reconversion dans la loi parce qu'elle
se pratique en France est-ce que
l'islamisme est une menace dans notre
pays
pas l'Islam Oui
je précise pas l'islam moi je vis dans
un département où beaucoup de mes
concitoyens pratiquent la religion
musulmane la pratique tranquillement et
sereinement ce qui est dangereux c'est
quand on a un islamisme politique
c'est-à-dire où certains veulent imposer
les règles et je pense notamment aux
femmes les règles
qui sortent de leur religion à toute la
société et ça on ne peut pas l'accepter
la laïcité c'est ça parce que islamisme
est féminisme ça fait pas bon ménage si
je puis dire mais
à partir du moment
où le corps de la femme devient un
danger
puisque c'est un danger parce que ça
peut tenter l'homme parce que la femme a
travers son corps peut corrompre l'homme
et donc il faut cacher ce corps quelque
part vous nier à la femme son droit tout
simplement d'être alors bien sûr c'est
complexe parce que chacun a sa religion
s'il le souhaite on peut aussi être
athées mais rien ne s'impose sur les
règles de la société alors il y a
quelqu'un qui avait une certaine idée de
la France vous allez reconnaître tout de
suite regarder je me suis en effet de la
France une certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressenti par
le monde entier
c'est vrai la France est une chose
à mes yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quel qu'il
soit tout époque naturellement d'après
les circonstances elle doit avoir un
rôle à elle il faut que la France joue
son rôle c'est exact et pour qu'elle
joue son rôle il faut qu'elle soit à la
France
les Français les Français ceux qui font
la France
c'est eux qui en sont responsables la
France est plus que les français du
moment
la France vient de loin
et avec qui qu'en face du général de
Gaulle évidemment et la France ce sont
les Français et en 1998 vous étiez
ministre de la Jeunesse et des Sports la
France a gagné la Coupe du Monde
première fois en France et on a célébré
à ce moment-là la France Black Blanc
beurre et j'ai relu récemment des
déclarations vous avez faites vous
disiez on a peut-être un peu exagéré
cette notion on a rêvé c'était pas la
réalité nous on passe
et donc on a rêvé que ça allait
permettre de rassembler de dépasser les
discriminations etc et très vite on
s'est aperçu qu'on avait rêvé et que la
réalité n'était pas celle-ci
le sport peut faire beaucoup de choses
l'individu pour son bien-être pour pour
la société parce qu'il rassemble parce
que mais le sport ne peut pas régler à
lui tout seul les dérives de la société
c'est pas le sport qui va régler les
inégalités sociales c'est pas le sport
qui peut régler les inégalités raciales
c'est pas le sport qui peut faire tout
ça
l'enthousiasme de la victoire moi je me
rappelle mon retour du Stade de France
ce soir là où les gens descendaient avec
des drapeaux etc et puis
quelques temps après il y a eu le match
de foot France - Algérie et on s'est
aperçu que les choses n'étaient pas
simples pas à travers l'invasion du
stade lui-même parce que il y a eu une
provocation je vois encore les personnes
qui ont provoqué la définition puis
après c'est les gamins les mômes qui
sont descendus pour approcher les grands
joueurs soit algériens ou français il y
a pas eu de violence bon mais après les
discours politiques qu'on a eu à partir
de ce match France-Algérie c'est
terrible quand même moi je me rappelle
des questions d'actualité qui ont suivi
c'était une violence sur les supporteurs
qui avaient choisi l'Algérie
voilà donc on s'était on a vite vu que
c'était pas réglé le nationalisme c'est
la guerre comme disait Mitterrand quand
vous avez l'idée que votre pays
doit dominer les autres automatiquement
vous créez la tension et vous trouvez
que la France a un peu cette supériorité
j'ai envie de dire avec tout le respect
que je dois au général de Gaulle que
peut-être qui
il avait une idée de la France peut-être
plus grande que elle n'était réelle
parce que bien sûr la France de par le
monde a été longtemps reconnue comme la
France
on disait des droits de l'homme moi je
dis la France des droits des êtres
humains
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui elle est six
modèles que ça enfin je veux dire je
vous pose la question je regardais
récemment
les classements alors on a monté un peu
sur par exemple la liberté des
journalistes et tout on est remonté un
peu mon anniversaire
je regardais aussi sur les accidents du
travail faut bien sûr pointer le Qatar
et ce scandaleux cette scandaleuse Coupe
du Monde au Qatar il rentre raisons mais
enfin il y a beaucoup d'accidents aussi
mortels dans le travail en France
nous ne faisons pas de nous un pays qui
serait le modèle
nous avons fait des choses importantes
la Révolution de 1789
il y a eu la résistance c'est des tas de
choses formidables mais il y a d'autres
peuples aussi qui ont mené des combats
remarquables et la France c'est un pays
démocratique c'est un pays qui qui a une
voix qui porte c'est vrai mais bon c'est
un petit pays par rapport aux grandes
puissances aujourd'hui et pour le parti
communiste moi j'ai le souvenir parce
qu'on parlait je vous disais est-ce que
le nationalisme c'est la guerre est-ce
que et le Parti communiste souvent
[Musique]
reprochent aux parties aux autres partis
justement d'être passé assez ouvert
d'être trop replié sur eux-mêmes de
défendre une France rabougri mais moi
j'ai le souvenir du Parti communiste de
Georges Marchais qui disait le travail
d'abord aux Français
oui vous êtes d'accord avec ça mais oui
enfin pas avec lui mais vous
reconnaissez que ça existait mais bien
sûr non mais je le nid est absolument
pas c'est l'histoire c'est un pont de
l'histoire du Parti communiste français
mais je pense que par exemple l'accueil
des hommes et des femmes qui fuient une
situation soit de guerre bien sûr et là
il y a l'asile politique et tout ça mais
une situation simplement de misère bien
il faut les accueillir en France et il
faut en effet partager avec eux les
ressources les richesses produites par
la France partager avec eux le travail
donner à leurs enfants
l'école publique c'était voilà c'est
magnifique que l'école publique soit
obligatoire pour tout enfant qui vit en
France je trouve ça magnifique il faut
que ça soit mis mise en oeuvre donc
c'est une singularité française
la France Marie-Georges Buffet elle est
à gauche ou à droite
si vous me disiez la France est-ce
qu'elle est toujours en train de
rouspéter je vous dirais oui
sauf que si le combat
c'est
le combat d'une partie du peuple contre
une autre partie du peuple c'est pas un
combat de gauche c'est pas des
références de la gauche moi je suis très
inquiète de
ces mouvements qui se créent qui sont
très limités dans leurs espaces et dans
leur mission vous savez où par exemple
le combat féministe est un combat qui
visait la domination patriarcale mettre
fin à domination patriarcale égalité des
droits etc partage du pouvoir etc et
vous allez maintenant des des bouts de
mouvement féministes qui se battent que
sur un aspect
[Musique]
justement on est en train de émietter
les cons parce que la gauche c'est pas
un peu perdu là dedans justement en
faisant la en faisant en épousant les
causes claniques finalement je le pense
parce que la gauche à la vocation
de tous ceux et celles qui vivent de
leur travail et ne pas choisir entre les
uns et les autres donc la gauche n'a pas
à
émietter son combat n'a pas émietté le
peuple dans différentes clans comme vous
l'avez dit dont le combat serait le
combat essentiel au détriment d'autres
combats etc je trouve que c'est
peut-être ça qui lui a fait perdre le
peuple aussi électoral et puis la
déception il y a eu ça et puis il y a eu
la gauche au pouvoir qui n'a pas tenu
ses engagements et
ça a été bon particulièrement vrai du
dernier de gauche
ou là les gens nous envolent je dis de
nous en vol parce que
ils en veulent à la gauche il y a les
parties dans la gauche mise en veulent à
la gauche
et si nous sommes pas capables dans les
dans les dans les mois qui viennent de
redonner une image d'une gauche
rassemblée mais rassemblée sur une
politique déterminée audacieuse on aura
de plus en plus de gens qui se
détacheront de la gauche et qui
exprimeront quand même leur colère parce
que leur vie est toujours aussi
difficile donc ils vont continuer à
exprimer leur colère mais pour aller où
je pose la question et bah ça peut être
des mouvements qui deviennent violents
qui deviennent anti républicains etc
anti républicain moi je retiens que la
France est une France en colère alors
vous parliez des paysages enfin vous
parliez de la Bretagne et de l'Ardèche
la France est procède de ces paysages
aussi ah oui parce que la France est
très diverses et puis moi je respecte
l'amour de
population pour leur région moi je suis
pas du tout bretonne mais je suis
bretonne d'adoption j'ai envie de dire
et vous acceptez les régionalismes oui
par exemple le fait que tous les Bretons
veulent faire vivre leur culture leur
langue leur langue tout en étant de la
République tout en étant des citoyens et
des citoyennes de la République ça c'est
normal c'est c'est faire vivre une
histoire ça fait vivre une culture et on
est riche de cette culture je vais vous
demander de vous livrer aux petits
questionnaire de Proust si la France
était un paysage puisqu'on parlait des
paysages de France ça serait lequel
alors c'est l'embouchure de la Laïka
elle Aita la mère voilà la mer rentre
Bretagne
la mère rentre et va monter pas jusqu'à
Quimperlé mais presque on avait de l'eau
salée
remonte assez loin c'est comme toutes
ces rivières bretonnes et alors c'est
magnifique vous voyez moi j'habite pas
très loin là-haut et on peut descendre à
pied là sur ces plages c'est je m'en
lasse pas
si la France était un écrivain
alors j'ai beaucoup hésité
pas pour rire mais j'ai dit genre chez
nous parce que je suis quelqu'un qui
fait des séries comme ça et alors en
seconde je faisais tout Émile Zola alors
et puis si non alors c'est à la fois
bien sûr le policier mais cetera mais
c'est deux livres en livre on change de
milieu c'est aussi une magnifique
chronique sociale sur la France de ces
années-là c'est une description de la
France de ces années là dans l'île dans
les bistrots dans les trucs voilà c'est
ton relie Simonon on s'imagine la France
photographie de la France
si c'était une toile de mettre une une
peinture alors j'ai choisi la femme à la
mandoline de Picasso une toile qui
remonte à 1909 parce que dans toute sa
carrière Picasso a peint des femmes
assises sur des fautes dans des
fauteuils alors au début c'était
classique si je dis ça peut-être que je
vais me faire reprendre par des
spécialistes mais classique et puis
jusqu'au cubisme on avait cette femme
dans les fauteuils etc et la femme à la
mandoline
elle est pleine de douceur elle est
pleine de voilà donc je trouve c'est un
tableau qui qui donne une belle image de
la femme un personnage historique leur
Claire Lacombe pourquoi Pierre Lacombe
parce qu'on a parlé de Robespierre
et souvent qu'on se représente les
femmes pendant la Révolution française
la grande révolution les deux images
qu'on voit c'est les femmes qui partent
à la Bastille et puis c'est les femmes
qui vont à Versailles alors on les
présente hurlant à vider presque les
manifestations pour le pain et tout ça
sauf que les femmes pendant la grande
révolution font beaucoup de politiques
il faut énormément de politiques plaire
la combe et tu actrice elle fait du
théâtre elle vient de Marseille Toulon
etc et puis elle adhère au club des
Jacobins
à la DR au club des femmes
républicaines et révolutionnaires
beaucoup de femmes s'engagent en
politique elles obtiennent des choses
moi j'ai une affiche j'ai fait ma carte
de vœux l'année dernière avec une
affiche qu'ils avaient publié dans tout
Paris où elle demandait le droit au
divorce parce que elle ne voulait pas
continuer à vivre et elle l'ont obtenu
très peu de temps mais elles l'ont
obtenu de la Révolution française donc
les femmes déjà à cette époque sont en
politique c'est dommage enfin c'est
dommage on entend pas tellement parler
de ça
on est face beaucoup trop les femmes de
l'histoire de France
voilà c'est tout les grands hommes vous
savez ces expressions les grands hommes
et encore il y a deux jours j'ai goûté
une émission à 20h ou je sais pas où
c'était une émission
il y avait pas de nous parler des hommes
politiques j'ai dit mazout s'embêtant
quoi
en politique moi qui suis-je une femme
merci Marie George Buffet merci beaucoup
de vous être prêté à cet exercice et de
nous dire un peu votre vision de la
France merci merci
[Musique]